there's a new monster in town merry Kish
it's scary it's the race
look at this nasty thing she's beast
kind of look like a xenomorph and
Carrigan if you look at the other
monsters think about it like B and D
Goliath is the fighter type Krakens
that's the mage and Rayce is the rogue
so it's all about getting in good
initiation and then kind of slyly
getting away fast damaging out yeah high
DPS but then you're also very squishy
you don't have a lot of health you have
very low shields even when you've
replenished them the thing with rape is
got these evasion abilities the first
one we'll talk about sort of the most
straightforward warp blast basically you
just zoom in to a point you warp in
there and then boom you do this area of
effect explosion so it's super good for
initial earning to skill-shot those
things to clear your line of sight so
you land where you want to is a skill
you develop one frame playing ray but
that warp in and blow up is not just a
great initiator it's also good for
hunting because you can catch up with
some critters and blow them up real
easily it's also good for denying a
revive because you know like you've
gotten away and they're like running
into revive the hunters and you're like
no I don't think so
the next ability kind of in the same
warping vein is abduction you actually
get these weird cone vision pick the
person zoom in grab the person you're
gross tentacles and zoom out you know
you don't get too many yards on but it's
enough where you get a good 5 to 10
seconds alone with whoever you've
abducted to do some serious damage alone
yeah and you you warp right back to
where you started from so positioning is
key here maintaining an open sight line
and as you level it up you actually do
increase the range pretty significantly
it is so satisfying when you just zoom
in and going somebody and then you
cruise back and you know it's gonna be a
little
I was playing his rape I grabbed you you
were the assault I had you all alone
after school Oh
I was like oh nothing you picked the
wrong one as soon as I caught my shield
there's really nothing for you to do you
actually left me but you know to your
credit though when you're taking people
away you're doing huge damage because as
a team that's the whole point is to do
damage as a unit all together and you're
picking someone off dropping them off in
the middle of you know Nowheresville
and then going after the team you just
they've just lost their major damage
dealer so even if even if you kind of
pick up the wrong guy it's a huge
problem every monster has unique
movement ability and the rates is warp
and it's basically just a dash but you
can do it in any direction you can do it
up into the sky onto a platform you can
do it like a laterally along the ground
one of the ones that absolutely destroys
our team I've been calling the murder
dome murder dump yep Super Saiyan sphere
was my alliterative take but it's called
supernova and basically what it does is
creates a little mini dome now it's not
like the mobile arena which controls
access in or out you can go in and out
of it hundreds can go in or out of it
just an area effect you attack much
quicker and you do more damage and you
just turn into this like crazy food
processor of death
the final ability is decoy now the decoy
this is so important does damage so you
can essentially pop your decoy and then
just sleuth away you become invisible
when you pop your decoy so as your
decoys doing damage everyone's going to
assume that that's you and you just you
just kind of sneak out of there and even
if they know that you've popped your
decoy the decoy is still attacking them
and doing damage still they have to pay
attention to it they have to account for
it otherwise they could get in cabs they
could lose serious health and then that
positions you to stealthily sneak up on
them and blend killing blow something
important to understand about the Eco is
that if you do any kind of physical move
if you try to do another move it will
erase your decoys so the point of the
decoy is to move into a better position
or to get out it's not to have double
damage you can't have you and your decoy
doing damages yeah and it can't be
popping other abilities but you can eat
that the best way to avoid damage is to
use your skills in tandem there are very
particular tactics that I found out very
quickly that made me almost it just felt
like I couldn't lose using these tactics
flash in and you explode that's your
initiator you pop your dome you do a
little bit of damage or chopping people
up that's right as fast as you can and
then when you got like five seconds left
you pop your your clone because what
happens is is if you pop your dome first
your clone gets the benefits of your
dome which means your clone is dealing
significant damage
so with these tactics what's the counter
right this became a real big question
because you and I played a bunch of
matches on the same hunter team and we
got shredded by a rape four games in a
row then I played as a wraith and played
against you and some other folks and
like three out of four it was deadly
rape times and it's I think one of the
big things is the rapes evasion game is
so strong how do you pin down the rate
the hunters are all about getting the
monster in that dome getting some traps
down getting some harpoons into them and
slowing them down but with the Wraith
decoy with the with the abduction being
able to like warp around there's so many
things in the wraiths favor for getting
it away from the hunters for letting the
Wraith control the engagement that it
just they kind of seemed over power yeah
she is completely different than all the
other monsters they all have their
different skills but when it comes to
rape it is so hard to do damage because
once the wraith feels like they're in
trouble
they just pop the clone and leave one of
the things to keep in mind though in
Mary is when we've played when he first
played Goliath when we first played
Kraken it did kind of feel like the new
monster was overpowered and so I think
counts our programming to the rates
abilities is even more essential you
know it seems like very specific things
you want some harpoons out there because
holding the wraith keeping it in place
is super important one of the new
hunters I believe Cabot has stasis
grenades which they blow up in an area
and then you'll get the monster will get
slowed and will get these kind of like a
little balls of light circling it to
indicate but there's no denying in my
opinion that race is going to be the one
for the experienced players and they are
interested in that more difficult
challenge of a monster because with that
challenge I think comes the most damage
of any monster might be a close
contender for my favorite monster of us